in these development days happens that
just few figures so far and certainly
the calculations by default 8700 more
participants registered and I'm sure
there many were unregistered irregular
participant to be with a bit of
solidarity with some of our friends from
Africa with in Europe the second 150
with under 18 actually journalists 50
partnership with the press and since we
are not good in counting you know we
didn't finish the list of the
quantitative indicators but since
inequalities who was a debate about not
only quantity but about the quality of
our they say joint work I can say that
the level of the debate a level of
participation the level of enthusiasm
that I've seen personally you know
around shows that this idea to talk
about the quality of the development and
not only about the indicator of the GDP
but to look at real substance as taken
and by the way I also noticed that as it
was logic to imagine that the link
between what Europe is doing outside and
what Europe is doing inside has been
underlined by many and I think that this
is very understandable because you know
when we say we are expressing in our
International Cooperation and
Development policy a bit the
characteristic of the union solidarity
inclusiveness well in the moment when we
spoke we give a spot on this
inequalities is more than normal that we
are asked yes but you are exporting
really inequalities to what is your
situation on this this is a way to let's
say to talk about the SDGs in a
different way we say the eg are global
ok this I think the message has been
seen and therefore you know many ask
Europe how you're doing and
therefore this I think is particularly
important to link this global agenda of
development of international cooperation
which wants to be a way of being Europe
value practice failures in the world to
share and to put something in motion as
a result of an alliance this is a bit
what I take out of this many panels many
discussion so beautiful day to say now
just not to spend too much time in other
words because there are many words I
would like to call on Alicia Barcena the
secretary the exactly circles of the
Japan to come here and to deliver say
some messages from the perspective of
multilateral and tell us a bit what has
been your experience what is your some
concluding say thinking about that and
the input for what next please dear
Commissioner Nevins me Missa there
Stefano months are busy they are all
distinguished and may be extinguished at
this point in time everybody I am here
also in representation of Antonio
Guterres the secretary-general of the UN
who has gave me that given me the task
of saying why why inequality is so
important why today and why here
basically I have to say that between the
UN and the European Commission there is
a common view of inequality inequality
set threat to sustainable development
this is what you say this is what we
also say so why is today the time for
equality first because inequality is
inefficient from the economic
perspective it's generating irreversible
costs to the economy secondly because
it's a right and it's a political and
ethical imperative
Punto
thirdly because it is time for
intergenerational equality and the
secretary-general has requested me to
speak about youth why is youth so
important I see a lot of young people
all people to have to say but young
people because the world is today
younger than ever
you know 1.8 billion are young people
between the ages of 10 and 24 and 4 out
of 10 for it 2% of the global population
is under 25 years old so this is
affording us an unprecedented
opportunity of social progress if we
make it right in my region Latin America
and the Caribbean we have a hundred and
sixty three million young people between
15 and 29 years old
however our region is at crossroads and
maybe use is also here at crossroads
maybe all over the world because what
happens is that one path symbolizes
promise expectations even promoted by
the media know they use the wonderful
the future whatever but on the other we
have the dangers of a slowdown of a once
promising economy which is posing
already threats to the economic and
social progress 64 of the young people
of my region is in living in poor or
vulnerable households 64 percent I mean
come on so what is going on and
therefore they don't have access to
education to good jobs and I think what
one of the aims of our region at least
is that these young people should have
secondary education and that is because
that is a window to go directly into the
technological revolution and vocational
training at least secondary school
because employment and decent work and
we have said this you have said it we
have said that I Allah has said all the
UN all over the world
decent jobs is the master key to combat
inequality and poverty and use in
unemployment has to be our first
priority
because this gives young people
emancipation liberty freedom and dignity
this is why I think we have to work on
these clearly because if not the shaft
disconnect between expectations and
realities are generating undermining
trust and social discontent and that is
why three one of three of you young
people do not want to participate in
electoral processes you are you're
abstaining you're saying why why should
I go I don't have anything to gain here
and also because we have to make sure
that we are also incorporating young
people because what's happening for
example in Latin America 1/5 1/5 of
these 163 million people are of young
people are in the informal sector and
another 1/5 are what we call in Spanish
the nenes the needs they're neither
study or work Tarara but this is very
unfair for women you know because the
majority of the needs or ninnies are
women because they are cut in teen
pregnancy or in the care economy with
non remuneration so unfairly they are
kept out of the labor market so we have
to work we have to do things so for me
this is one of the greatest
inefficiencies of inequality from the
economic perspective to leave the
demographic bonus all these young people
out what are these young people doing
well they go to drugs or to illegal
economy this is happening in Central
America who are the ones why migrating
young people from 15 to 25 years old so
that's the problem but the young people
want to participate right because you
don't want to be only the object
of policies you really want to be part
and I think this is what we're talking
about and this is why equality has to be
a driver of growth and in my region we
are combatting also the culture of
privilege because in our region there
are many privileges the elite you know
the ones who always win the winners of
everywhere the usual suspects and what
happens in a region like ours the
indigenous peoples and the
afro-descendants are the ones who are
suffering the most because they were
either on forced labour or slavery the
land was expropriated their beliefs and
their values were suppressed so we have
to young people use of this room in a
world over the world we have to combat
that and who is showing us a way greater
sunberg that young woman who has led the
largest youth protest in the whole of
history because we are I mean me
unfortunately you unfortunately our
generation we are responsible of this
inter generation myopia we you're not we
are and this is what greata told us that
we are probably the first generation
that has all the information to combat
climate change and poverty and we're
probably the last that can do something
about it and this was not said by me
people say I think by President Obama
and many people repeated it but this is
true and the other thing is that in this
digital world you are the first
generation of digital natives we're
struggling my generation struggling to
understand it but you're not you grow
you are growing with digital things so
what we need to ensure is that you also
take care of the digital divide and
that's what I'm calling for dear
colleagues we must invest today
and that's why the United Nations has
made a strategy on youth Antonio
Guterres has been very very firm on this
and we have to make sure that we combat
inequality because inequality conspires
against development
let me today dear colleagues I want to
really pay a special tribute to Stefano
man service and to nevins Mimi's if you
allow me I will ask for a big applause
[Applause]
yes I have many years many years in
multilateral cooperation and the legacy
of these two is going to be impressive
you're going to remember mark my words
development in transition climate change
erima oh my goodness you have made a
great difference and allow me just to
finish an end by recalling one of Latin
American greatest poets Mario Benedetti
of uru why he wrote the poem that said
what is left to the young he said still
left to you the young is to recover
speech and nutopia to be young with no
rush but with memory to extend a helping
hand to open the doors from your heart
to the heart of others most of all is is
left to you to build the future
despite the ruins of the past and the
sage billions of the present thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you very much easier and thank you
very much through you to Antonio
Guterres and all the commitment that UN
system is putting in not only defending
but promoting multilateralism and on
this european union is at the forefront
or the ambition to remain and the
forefront but without your support could
be just an empty statement so is living
i would like now to call here some well
eager someone please someone is an
ethiopian concert pianist which is part
of the so called my Kshatriya Myesha
trio has been an invention they say no a
project which has been promoted by our
delegation to the european union in
addis abeba jean is with us with all our
colleagues which have been working on
that is a and experience of euro afro
music or afro European music and I think
it is extremely exciting because the
project of doing together and producing
also they say a sort of mix but not
accumulation a reason mixed and I think
that some well who by the way I mean
having the privilege to been in Ethiopia
several time I was very much
appreciating on a personal basis the
contribution to the Renewable of the
European jazz which is absolutely
fantastic therefore someone pleased with
your group you know we have here a bass
in the end the percussion just to
perform a bit of this maisha which for
those which are interested then will be
also available on they say on a digital
support because really was was having
this and listening to someone this with
your group
take this take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so since now they have to change a bit
the stage I'm told and therefore have to
improvise a bit I think the best way is
to give you a bit the floor to explain a
bit this much experience and also a bit
of touch of your music because this is I
think would be a great interest of all
the audience you experience what you
took out of it what next about about
Masha
yeah Masha was really interesting and
amazing project that I've been part we
had six musicians from Europe and six
musicians from Africa and within a very
short time we delivered something
amazing as a musician I didn't expect
that's a short time to deliver such a
beautiful result the beauty of fusing
cultures or gathering together within
culture is that you understand the
values you understand the problems of
each other and you become someone to
bring the solution so we use the music
to bring solution as a continent it was
like one small world in one small
compound but our world was far away from
that compound away from that area we
were together so the result was amazing
I am sure people will love it yeah thank
you
thank you very much
[Applause]
so now I think we are ready to pass
through the next phases but this is real
great music or like say not only the
Meisha but Sammy in this group is really
fantastic so let's try and find a way to
distribute the mission experience in our
delegation by the way thank you very
much John because you are doing a lot of
good job in addis abeba thank you and so
because it's really good good piece of
music not only the result by the way the
link between the collosseum culture and
here you know which in the making and I
think it was telling now Mass please
come along NASA is well known I think as
you call it influencer many people oh my
god since you have been travelling you
have three million thirteen million
followers yes today now you know you
have traveled to 61 countries in one
thousand a doing one minute video this
congratulations you've done better than
me one mission very good I have to learn
how to do videos maybe yeah therefore
you have the best they say no actor and
to tell us a bit what is your pitch
about inequalities in the world what
you've seen great what you can tell us
all right I'm gonna talk for 10 minutes
yeah what then and I'm gonna use slides
you go slides you see okay alright I'm
gonna address them is that okay yeah
thank you so much for the introduction
hi everybody
how are you I flew for 15 hours from
Singapore to come here and talk to you
for 10 minutes so you please you better
pay attention anyway for those that are
not familiar with my work
my name is nas from Mass daily a little
bit about me my name is no sire Yassin
it's a complicated name I grew up in
Israel as a Palestinian
it's even more complicated if an
upbringing and I decided to go by the
name nos because it's just much easier
what do I do
I just make videos and I put them on the
internet it's as simple as that I
decided to quit my job and try to make
1,000 videos in 1,000 days the videos
are about anything that I care about if
I care about something I make a video
about it and I put it on the internet
and it's no more than 60 seconds the
videos I decided to make them not just
from New York
not just from Los Angeles but also from
55 different countries to my surprise
people actually wanted to watch these
videos they were viewed of a total of 4
billion times on Facebook and amassing
over 13 million followers of this 1000 a
journey it blew all my expectations
now this journey was the hardest thing
I've ever done but also one of the most
insightful things I've ever done and the
one question the one question people
tell me nos what has the thing what was
the thing that impacted you the most out
of this 55 country journey well that
question is inequality let me tell you a
story I was in India in Mumbai making
videos and I decided to splurge for one
day and I decided to stay at the Four
Seasons Hotel for one night it was $300
per night and I paid it I go to this
suite I love it it's nice its spacious
its luxurious
I opened the curtains and I see poverty
lots and lots of poverty I see slums the
Four Seasons apparently was built right
next to slums and that was the first
time in my life where I saw extreme
income inequality it made me
uncomfortable because I was there
spending $300 a night for a bed and
these guys next to me no more than 10
meters were spending $300 a year to live
that obviously there's something wrong
with that so I made a video about it and
to my surprise again millions of people
cared about this topic millions of young
people on Facebook or Instagram really
cared about this
and it bothered them a lot so the next
day I decided to take it a step further
I decided to try to live like a poor
person like one of the people in those
slums in Mumbai according to the World
Bank you are only poor if you live under
one dollar and ninety cents per day so I
decided to live on a dollar and ninety
cents for one day
and guess what it was really really hard
the whole day for 24 hours I had to only
think about saving money getting free
water not bottled water because it's too
expensive
I actually got food poisoning from bad
water by poisoning to sleep in places
that are not hotels to sleep in like
like like like a Sikh temple or on the
streets and to also eat the leftovers
that the poor people would you normally
eat and that 24 hours has literally
transformed my life because it made me
realize the only thing I was thinking
about is how the hell do I survive I
wasn't thinking about going to
conferences I wasn't thinking about
making videos I wasn't thinking about
building a business I was only thinking
about how to survive I made a video
about that topic as well and as expected
this topic resonates with millions and
millions of youth people around the
world it's something that a lot of
people care about now this experience
has taught me that there are two worlds
there's not one world that's a lie
there's two worlds one for the further
for the not poor and one for the poor
for the not poor you buy $60 shirts no
problem for the poor you have to settle
for the last one for that further for
the poor you have to eat the biryani for
the rich you have to eat the
nice-looking food and not only is it
food not only is it closed not only is
it house it's also opportunity it's also
education and and that is what resonated
a lot with people income inequality is
not just a problem in India it's
actually all over the world and do you
know how easy it is in today's world to
show it you just take a camera
turn it on and take a picture and you
get something like this
that's that picture speaks a thousand
words it talks about ink the the the
systemic failures of a society the
systemic failures of a country and it's
not just Brazil it's many countries
around the world and all it takes is to
take a picture put it in the Internet
and millions of youth are gonna share it
we share it share it again and they're
gonna get angry it's a problem it's a
bigger bigger bigger bigger bigger
problem
it exists in Brazil a lot of it exists
in South Africa and a lot of it exists
back home where I come from between the
Jews and the Arabs and now the next
question I'm always asked is well not
how do we fix income inequality luckily
I don't have to answer that question
it's not my job my job is to show you
income inequality the people's job is to
be angry about it and your job as the
government is to fix it it's as simple
as that because it is my deep belief not
you not and and it is really my deep
belief that in the next five to ten
years more and more people will have
drones more and more people will put
this stuff on Facebook more and more
this income inequality problem will
become a bigger problem and I really
hope that you guys do something so that
for so that the poor people can stop
thinking of how to survive and start
thinking of how to live thank you guys
so much for your time and thank you for
having me they appreciate it
thank you thank you thank you what if
there was a case to to explain what
inequalities are from different parts of
the world you gave it with one exception
the plate I think that the biryani was
better than thank you so much like the
general appreciated thank you for your
time so thank you very much nest and
then you know I think we should do more
influencing even if you don't like the
name but let's influence in this way you
know that that people wake up and see
what's going on in the world so now we
have the panel with the young leaders
therefore I would like to call here
Leticia Bao mwah Muto the recipient from
Brazil from Brazil so therefore you can
ask her okay male Muto from Zambia
rejoicing amoled from Malawi and and
margarita founder/director of the Uganda
landmine survival Association and around
Google is ITC
[Applause]
so here we are a bit with this young
leader say don't know if I have yeah it
is a place for me to also who is missing
he is missing Margaret where's Margaret
welcome
[Applause]
so in short because you know the young
leader they have been with us very often
I mean it's an idea that we have in
order to not only to give voice but to
give protagonism to young and at the
same time leaders so meaning not only
giving impulse but also taking
responsibility of what is going on I
think that this is interesting because
we have since we started this in 2015
and we had 16 young leaders so far from
41 countries 404 young leaders
application this year so you are the
happy few
and these they're in representation of
the 15 which have been selected out of
these 404 so I think that by the way
it's quite easy to start a question to
Leticia because you are confronted with
the climatic picture about Brazil she's
a rich country now GDP like and g20 like
many other but you know what what is the
situation from your point of view what
else the biggest challenge that not only
in Brazil but in general you think that
should be addressed youth are catalysts
also change and we are at the front
front forefront of driving sustainable
developments around the world so I speak
now in their names and due this week we
are here to discuss the qualities
between and within countries however
these inequalities will not be addressed
unless we act immediately on climate
change and that was what I want to
emphasize today as youth we are aware of
the importance of investing in long-term
gains that will benefits not only us but
future generations
and when we visit the EU polish lab at
the joint research centre climate change
environmental degradation where one r14
megatrends megatrends give us first
sight and as everybody here know climate
change now have the potential to us in
all the SDGs
it's as a particular effects in
agriculture migration health peace
production and conception action for the
environment can have a long-term
positive impact across all sectors it's
most important as we discussed the a
general trend study to also think of the
urgent agenda of the next few years we
need actions we need actions have a
strong and sustainable impact this is
why we are demand for actions not Mary's
promises climate change you must be
included and parasite in be a priority
as part of the political agenda
involving policies but also adequate is
a potential fanzine there is a strong
home for all levels and actors which
should be recognized including the local
authorities we should ensure a local
approach in addition to our national
frameworks fighting against this climate
crisis by 2015 by 2050 two-thirds of our
many will be urban sustainable
development cannot be achieved without
changing the way we build and manage our
cities we need to design smart and
sustainable cities which are also
inclusive so far our cities are being
flooded
millions live in slums not having
something as basic as a bathroom and
water we are being suffocated by
pollution of interesting cars we could
leave each disasters for you here today
but you are already aware we make you
see our cities as part of the problem
but we can also see them as a lever for
change we young people we want
investment in public transportation we
want to bring spaces in a city wearing
we can walk without having to cough up
pollution everything that we are
discussing right now will not be
possible if women are not at the table
if the youth and the most vulnerable
communities are not at the table because
the path to sustainability will be
punked out by those historically
excluded from power we are aware that so
much needed climate change action
demands funding we are anticipated
that's why we urgently ask our
governments should not only create
public policies but also deliver action
by finding new sources of financing like
the sustainable use of a public
procurement as youth around the world we
are doing our job we are striking we are
here
we are counseling him reminding everyone
that's not longer a climate change but I
climate emergency to our mayor's
presidents and ministers we are not here
beg for your help we are here to demand
your action and accountability thank you
thank you answer what do you think
urgency use a disaster of climate
Margaret
although the queries to comment alright
okay thank you thank you very much for
that elaborate presentation and bringing
the voice of youth into this arena where
we all gathered to try to find the
solution of making our world a better
place it's true that youth a catalyst
for change and it's true that most of us
who are here will sort of phase off and
then they use take off from where we
have left and the youth definitely need
that empowerment they need all that
support to enable them curry up the work
that we have the bigger challenge that
the world is facing is in the area of
climate change and I've seen a lot of
youth initiatives in tree-planting
there are some of these areas where we
can also try to alleviate or to reduce
on some of the impacts by planting trees
by you talked about the designs of the
cities where floodings happen and these
floodings also not only make the city
and pleasurable but also causes death
and brings also more sickness and
disease which in the end also needs a
lot of funds to be able to to care for
so yes
the inclusiveness designs in the cities
that has much and not of a flooding and
the safety that you mentioned is really
very imperative for total inclusion of
all people and here I speak on an angle
like of a person for disability and I
also know that with most of these
designs and plans that we can put in
place to alleviate some of this is the
work of civil society to carry out the
advocacy so a united voice between civil
society organizations
Youth and including government can bring
about some positive change thank you
well let me say that this year that I
love that you started with this
long-term view because I think part of
the problem we have is this short
termism that is ingrained in our system
governments are only thinking about how
they win the next election businesses
are only thinking of the next quarter
profit margins we are all impatient
impatient impatience the result of which
is that we are not thinking in 30 50
hundred years terms which is where we
are not thinking of what we are leaving
to the future generations so I really
love that you bring this issue of long
term to us as I like a lot that you ask
us to maybe you've been very diplomatic
so let me just try to be very little
diplomatic you've basically told us
enough talk just get to do stuff and
what I thought listening to you we could
all do is as we leave this room before
we cross the door we think of the one
thing we are going to do and the next
few weeks in the next few months that
will help us address inequality and
maybe starting with the inequality that
really bothers me which is the
inequality between men and women and
maybe
maybe we expand it a little bit not just
men and women but we also think in LGBT
those that don't think in binary
categories so thank you for that the
teacher do you find inspiration and the
Lions support for this I do think what I
think that we have to understand this
inequalities
it's true it's a reflection of the
structure of our society and to change
and to address this inequality we need
to bring those who are our historically
excluded to power women indigenous
people black people we need that most
vulnerable communities should be heard
and to act because those are will point
out the path first it's nobility yeah
now after having identified the issue
and also define a bit of completing this
in particularly on the gender
voilá if we look a bit forward I mean
how we can work in partnership in order
to to personalize all this to work to
bring it forward as a concrete agenda in
partnership thank you very much for the
opportunity you know as young people
every time when we sit and listen to our
police makers and government officials
telling us about sustainable development
it is very interesting the figures are
very nice the articulations are always
okay but when we sit in our circles we
ask ourselves the question where do they
go wrong because we don't see the impact
now that is why we have to speak about
addressing the inequalities because it
seems that there is a lot of money that
is being pumped in fostering the 2030
agenda but there is very little impact
because the resources are not being
distributed equally and I think it's
important that the EDD the EDD of this
year has focused very much on addressing
the inequalities addressing the
inequalities between girls and boys
addressing the inequalities between
young women and men addressing the
inequalities between rural and urban
youth because this is very much
important if we are to foster sustained
development in our communities it is
important that we start investing much
more in job creation in vocational
training trainings for young people in
digital markets in ensuring that young
people are more involved now as young
people who are here at the EDD we are
recommending two things that are
supposed to be done the first thing we
want to recommend for more investment in
youth and youth led organizations serve
our development partners as young people
we don't want to sit on the discussion
table as spectators or victims that need
help we want to be key partners in
development we want to be involved in
decision-making we want to be involved
in decision-making in government
positions we want to be involved in
private sector as key contributors
running businesses we want to be
involved in international development so
that we can also bring the youth vision
of the problems that are facing the
world currently it is very important
that you have invited us to come and
speak to this event and this shows that
the voice of youth is being held and it
just requires that the voice is more
bowed and louder so that impact can be
seen in our communities these are the
kind of partnerships that I needed first
and foremost we need to ensure that
young people are also benefiting from
the funding that is given to
organizations in most cases when we
speak about funding funding is directed
to bigger organizations of which in most
cases there is no youth representation
it is good that we have come up with
initiative like the air.you EU youth hub
which is a very good initiative that
will assist in fostering sustainable
development on the African continent but
as young people we feel that some of the
conditions that are set in the core of
proposals that are there for funding are
too stringent for our little
organization or our youth led
organizations to meet for example a
condition that you need to have at
previous funding of 2 million euros for
you to access the funding that is there
is too much we can't afford it most of
the youth led organizations don't have
such previous fundings before therefore
it is important that the funding
opportunities for young people are
opened up that we can also be inclusive
because if you keep on putting this
stringent measures it is only the use of
bigger organizations where there's no
use representations who continue
participating and when
they go on the ground they will not
involve us they'll just go ask our
workshops and there's nothing that is
done for us the next thing is that there
must be more investments in ensuring
that young people are going to be
involved in different activities that
are there young people are going to be
involved in the procurement system young
people are going to be involved in
fostering climate change and creating an
enabling environment for the achievement
of the sustainable development goals the
second thing is invest in
gender-responsive financial services we
cannot address inequalities without
addressing the gender gap and we have to
start addressing the gender gap from the
youth if there is inequalities among
boys and girls the gender gap was to
continue therefore it's important that
doors are opened for the girls my
education as a boy should not be
prioritized over the education of my
sister my sister should not be sold out
because I am supposed to go to school
therefore we need to check into
consideration all these issues as we are
speaking about sustainable development
the women they have to be empowered
because these are our mothers when you
go on the ground you realize that the
women and the ones who hold our homes
some of us were raised by single parents
so it's important that women are given
access to financial literacy are given
access to finance through loans women
can have bank accounts women can have
access to ownership when you go in most
of the developing countries to be
specific in Africa most women don't have
access to ownership of land they have to
go through their husband and when the
marriage ends they lose any everything
therefore it's important that women are
financially empowered also now the
question is how do we foster all these
issues that I've spoken about
partnerships it is very important that
we foster partnerships when it comes to
sustainable development and when we
speak about partnership it is not just
about partnership with the public sector
in most cases as international
corporations when we speak about
partnership you only want to focus on
government but they are also private
organizations that can yield more
benefits if you go on the ground you
realize that there's a lot of manner
that is pumped in the public sector in
the government's they'll say we are
going to empower young people in this
particular food but when you go on the
ground the manna is used to buy
expensive vehicles the manna is used for
workshops where they'll be paying
themselves Padilla's
so it's important that we can
the private sector also public-private
partnerships is very important I'll give
a perfect example of a public-private
partnership that can work very well in
Africa we have an organization called
the Tony L Miller foundation it empowers
a number of young people every year they
found one thousand young people trained
them in businesses this year they have
funded three thousand young people and
it's actually good that other
international organizations have come on
board like the African Development Bank
the UNDP to support or the SOL this is
good partnerships that can foster
sustainable development in the
developing world and as young people we
are here to say we are committed to
ensuring that this agenda is focused and
we are going to be key partners in
sustainable development
[Applause]
[Music]
well you've been particularly
represented table the young leader let
me tell you two things Mahalo first that
I fully agree with you - with your -
asks on your first task which is invest
in youth you know I was once once upon a
time I was also a young woman here in
Brussels and I used to hate it when
people would say oh you know we are
working to provide you with
opportunities and to empower you so I
would suggest that you do what I thought
I had to do which is just go and run
with it don't ask for permission just go
and do wherever you see the opportunity
don't wait go the second is an offer
like this is all about she trades women
in trade and youth and train young
people trading young startups 21st of
November are this that week we will be
holding together with the EU and the AU
a youth and conference whereby amid
seller investor meets investi
influencers meet potential clients and
where you will get a chance to say what
you want how you want it and from one
you want it thank you
Monday Tuesday youth Wednesday Thursday
women so all of you invite the 21st of
November Addis Ababa
[Applause]
you see civil societies yes and global
organizations serve over time spoken in
a united voice to establish common
position on global issues including that
one of youth and test yielded a great
impact and their collaboration with
state entities no doubt is one of the
best channels supporting actions for
positive change we know that we have
governments in place and we have
ministries and certain within the
ministries they're responsible
ministries for youth issues it is also
imperative for youth to be able to tap
into the development programs within
these government ministries it is a
channel where they can start from we
know also that investing in job creation
is one thing but the mindset of white
colored job needs to change because I
have seen many graduates from the
University three years four years after
graduation no job because they are
looking for a white-collar job maybe you
could invest in looking at creating jobs
interpreter ship that can enable youth
to be able to earn this decent living we
know adults are that civil societies I
needed for development and youth can
also be part of this body and we know
that the civil society bringing the
Global Agenda into the national
priorities and complement government
efforts so definitely we can't leave
youth behind and we need to work hand in
hand with the youth
I appreciate the voices of youth because
they are the voice of change thank you
mother
action with wisdom what do you think
about this support Oh the support for
you you have a call just run and then
Margaret said yes but look at the
content now I've been inspired by this
to build partnership yes very much
inspired actually and II would want to
be more involved and we appreciate the
work that you are doing so far and we
are willing that is why four hundred
young people applied to come here this
shows that it wants to come forward okay
speaking about the issue of moving away
from white-collar job I'm glad to
mention that of the 15 young leaders
that we have here more than half of them
are running their own registered
organizations creating jobs so what we
just need more empowerment more
engagement then we are going to be
partners in development good yes now
rejoice yes now we talk about the
framework we thought about the
partnership action with the Meseta
well which are which are the priority
which pilot action okay everything has
been say thank you mala and Leticia now
I will speak about education and
effective youth participation which my
fellow young leaders and youth at large
believe are directly linked now there's
about 200 million youth in Africa thus
there's a high demand on job creation
for us but now when you look at
impoverished communities the youth are
actually the breadwinners in their
families so now you're asking them to
either choose between quality education
or feeding their families which is very
inconsiderate so why don't we find a
mechanism to actually integrate
education and economic prosperity that
is why I believe that education and
economic prosperity are go hand in hand
or collaborative however really youth
are now concerned about the scope the
quality and the delivery of education we
believe that the current education
system is not matching with the 21st
century needs as I already said were
asked to be in school full-time but
we're also asked to create businesses
for our economy
now there needs to be a link there's
needs to be a balance that should be
created education needs to encompass
both soft and hard skills theoretical
and practical skills vocational skills
digital skills something that can enable
you to sustain early help themselves and
their families while still acquiring
high levels of education so that they
can be able to also stand here and
effectively communicate to everyone in
our audience just as I just as we as the
young leaders here are doing not
opposing education yeah an economic
activity what do you think okay it's not
that we are opposing education versus
the economic activities but we are
saying that there's been a lot in
education there's been opportunities but
the lack of jobs if we are going to sit
and wait until jobs are created that
would be the big challenge so as in
insists there is need to take initiative
and create jobs I know of in the area
that I live in a graduate who failed to
get a job and she decided to take on
West disposal collecting garbage from
housing estate and this is a housing
asset of over 2,000 homes and she has
opened up like three or four different
branches and is doing extremely well and
is also an employer so these are just
some of the areas I'm citing not that
I'm saying it's not right to have
education and then going for low menial
jobs
[Music]
this is a topic that is very close to my
heart my dad was a teacher yeah my
brother is a teacher my uncle was a
teacher and I'm a part-time teacher and
what in my view allows us to stand on
two feet is the ability that we have to
feel that we have the skills that we
need in order to go out there and rock
now I think the biggest challenge we
have today on education is not acquiring
knowledge it's learning to learn yes we
are going to have and we just had a
panel before this one devoted to
education the biggest challenge we have
whether it's in Africa in Europe in
America anywhere is that we're going to
have to change jobs many times many more
times in your lifetime than in a Stephan
or my time and that requires learning to
learn and that's a whole new skill that
is not just transferring knowledge ok I
just wanted to mention that skills
acquisition is one thing but now youth
are being faced with limited financial
assistance we have vibrant ideas
exceptional ideas in all regions Africa
Asia and Beyond but we're still being
asked to provide high value assets such
as a car vehicle and how do you expect a
17 year old with an amazing brilliant
idea to be able to provide this when
they're living on a dollar a day it
makes no sense therefore my advice is to
isn't twofold it is at policymakers
firstly policymakers ensure that youth
are at all levels of decision making
especially the initial phases when
you're setting the agenda Youth should
be included if it is for youth it should
be biased if it's not then it is against
you so let's ensure that youth are
relevance that are creating relevant
policies because they will enhance our
good governance systems to use as well
it is important to have financial
assistance it is great but I would
advise you to to to to flow
to flourish with the scarce resources
that you have flourish with the scarce
resources that you have if your talent
is speaking be able to to speak well be
able to sell your product your service
an investor will then be attracted to
your idea and it can it can be executed
so find ways and mechanisms of making
your dream become a reality this is this
is a powerful call for standing for use
Letitia well what do you think is sort
of after this change have you better
equipped your support you feel supported
you feel that once back as a young
leader you can drive your community
including your supporters here the other
young leaders you know in order to
generate movement because I want me to
say partners can do a lot but if you
don't stand for your future is difficult
so what what do you take out about this
ladies here since I arrived here I was
inspired not only for the other speakers
that was impressive speakers in these
rooms but mostly for my young colleagues
that are the front it's really our honor
should we speak in their behalf and it's
really important to understand their
links of all the subjects that we
discussed today education how it impacts
health how it affects also City Planning
and also gender equality
there are cross-cutting subjects we
cannot tackle one inequality without
things though but seeing the whole
spectrum and that's what I believe in
the EDC thinking of how we can link and
cooperate to build a better society well
I think I'm very happy to be in this
place it was my first time to come to
Europe and I was very excited when I got
on the plane
and meeting all of you that are here the
Commissioner the DG the senior EU
officials were very friendly they gave
us concrete information for the
first time I've gotten to understand
what the European Union is the European
Commission the European Parliament these
attempts that we just I've gotten a
number of business cuts here some people
have already invited me for certain
meetings and this is what sustainable
development is you have brought us on
the discussion table and we are
committing ourself that we are going man
we partners by engaging you more thank
you I think to to think one I always
consider partnership is bi-directional
so therefore we allow you but you're
encouraging us which is I think
Commissioner very important not to give
this in order to invest in use invest in
use and invest in use this is the
message thank you very much to all of
you thank you to all the other leaders
which were just represented just
standing please and thank you for this
so now we have a small film small movie
which is showing what we have been doing
these live during these two days then
the Commissioner Minister will deliver
the closing speech and after we have
another musical show we have the magic
system which will perform another music
so the small movie then if you want to
remain here will go down in the case
actually much small movie then
Commissioner minutes and then magic
system from ivory coast movie first
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
solidarity set up the broth the to live
you'll see samples a shotgun
don't be lost digitality operas kill
forty damn it
[Music]
[Applause]
now Commission 11 minutes sir please if
I may say just one thing they are good
Commissioner as a politician but also in
more rare good Commissioner because they
are really living a human trace in what
they did because believing supporting
and having a human dimension that
everybody will will recall because of a
president thank you very much
commissioner evening distinguished
participants the colleagues and friends
after a wonderful display of music and
film and inspiring words of Nass Velarde
Joyce and Leticia it is now my turn to
thank you from the bottom of my heart
too for another successful edition of
the European development days over the
past two days we have come together
young and old men and women from
different walks of life and from
different corners of the world to
discuss learn and inspire each other as
we continue our quest to leave no one
behind there is no denying that we have
a mountain to climb to reach the summit
the summit being a peaceful and
prosperous world free from poverty and
hunger to conquer this mountain we have
to conquer inequalities inequalities
stand in the way of sustainable
development for all by 2030 they hinder
economic growth and undermine the
effectiveness of our development efforts
they threaten democracy stability and
social cohesion they leave those least
responsible for climate change and
mental problems suffering the most the
2030 agenda provides us with an
unprecedented opportunity for positive
change from decent jobs and economic
growth to good health and quality
education to the empowerment of women
and girls the sustainable development
goals can be formidable tools for
addressing all kinds of inequalities so
how exactly can we grasp this
opportunity and what can we change in
our development cooperation to achieve a
real impact just a few days ago the
European Commission published a
reflection paper reflection document on
addressing inequalities in our partner
countries it shows just how serious we
are about putting inequalities front and
center of the european union's external
action it looks for example at how we
make inequalities part and parcel of our
development programs and projects in a
way that really makes a difference to
people on the ground this means adapting
to the specific circumstances of each
partner country it means integrating in
the qualities in the European Union's
multi-annual programming phase and it
means systematically at assessing and
taking into account how people in
different parts of the income
distribution are going to be affected by
new initiatives but ultimately what will
really determine our success in our
quest to leave no one behind
is the strengths of our partnership
there is scope for the European Union to
bolster strategic partnerships with
institutions like like the World Bank
the International Monetary Fund with the
UN systems and agencies and we also need
to work further with financial
institutions particularly when it comes
to implementing our external investment
plan and needless to say civil society
plays a critical role as watchdogs
advocates for equality and agents of
change these are partnerships that we
must continue to protect and cherish so
ladies and gentlemen this is the last
time I will be addressing the European
development days in my capacity as a
commissioner for International
Cooperation and Development so it is
with emotion that I deliver this closing
speech truly proud and humbled looking
back to what we have achieved since I
stood before you for the first time back
in 2015 we adopted the most ambitious
global blueprint for prosperity and
peace in history of mankind
the 2030 agenda for sustainable
development and we geared the
international cooperation of the
European Union and its member states
towards the achievement of these global
goals through a new European consensus
on development we launched the process
that will culminate in a new partnership
between the European Union and African
Caribbean and Pacific States after the
expiry of the current Cotonou agreement
next year we teamed up with the United
Nations for the spotlight initiative
unprecedented in terms of scale and
scope to eliminate all forms of violence
against women and girls
and we revolutionized our approach to
development financing adding the
European external investment plan in our
array of tools which is expected to
leverage 45 billion euros of new
additional investments by 2020 in Africa
and the European neighbourhood the first
European development days took place in
2006 under the auspices of my dear
predecessor commissioner lui Michele we
have come a long way since then we
closed the chapter of the Millennium
Development Goals and opened the one of
the sustainable development goals we
moved from a perception of development
defined in terms of us and recipients of
aid towards a global partnership
encompassing countries at all stages of
development and we have given to young
people civil society the private sector
academics and innovators their right
will sit at the table to come up with
joint solutions to the common challenges
we face yes we still have some roads to
travel to get to where we need to be by
2030 however looking around the room at
this development community and the next
generation of leaders I am confident
that our future is in safe hands so
thank you thank you all for your energy
your passion and your drive to make our
world a better place so thank you once
again very much for your engagement for
your enthusiasm for your contribution to
the sustainable development goals to
fighting inequalities and now the better
part of my closing
intervention comes with music thank you
[Applause]
good magic system now by the way I have
also another suggestion since this will
be also my last time and my job is
records he maybe not you could be
interested in taking this one you'll be
very good in this so magic from Cote
d'Ivoire now touring around and doing
around Africa and maybe doing around
also Europe one day on what makes Africa
and Europe friends about values about
challenge about explaining a bit Europe
in a better way that we are able to do
very often you know a bit in the nasty
that's where the blood and then with
music and going around and being you
know the best ambassador of this
different way of seeing the partnership
which is not necessary a master plan as
people say but rather a real friendship
and partnership in building a better
future for everybody as commissioner
Mimi's just said so now the magic system
I think is arriving slowly on scene I
would sit and watch
Hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
mr. magic system booty
the sinews
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
impressive Sipapu sake no sunglasses o
oppressor proposes Africa to monitor
magic system avec la musique Manos
Avenue C avec mes Astra's important
diffusers wa totemo Vasquez treasure
epigraph total Arabic onto de la fête du
côté de la vida es las tres important
Provo to search in Anoka n'est pas salut
group magic system movin on de la cote
Eva Lucien parte del pesci Katya privada
bgallagh pal a new Mambo Mousavi Kampala
Donegal ET des illegal tennis a party
desequerah Menounos abolishes de parte
de la rabbit ear moon excellent Korea a
LAN or Cardozo / me a tratar de tolly a
cultural open cultural aunt la freak
Europe me llamo Madonna comparable
catchy Sweden VT regard a doll retro
Viva la Vida regarding analysis under a
new - Aunt Viv la muchacha en vivo
Pascal illegalities aqua Lilly ghalichi
cerca de San fermín pala mentions a
lolicon Lilly ghalichi say collagen 500d
sapless say detrol oxygen atom mama
labelled associate Dahlia Nicole MOOC ad
a moment oniy if Al Arabi nian area
Pascaline de Valera the magic system a
diagram pipette artist Sawa valor
reportage on Sadie overhead row level
Akeno zvonaryova Sadd no Oliver
difficult a panic on a Nevada difficult
a [ __ ] swanee ovum a [ __ ] Lazio
fondazione kiva permit patrolman posture
no Sun Panetta Nozomi petty group mama
permit ascertain fund approval a local
convertible Emma Dharma today populace
old approval successfully
circumcircle Clara from - imagine system
in cell phone - oh no / moussaka
avvocato auditor avec le petit
spectacular Parsifal ah Lucas we will
call the cyclist 2 parameters of
analogical in shackles on cosmic
illusory Newsom a sinkhole magic system
Maternity
Hideko latest new APIs are a Salma
Avenue des album affirmance Adagio
latticed Caesarea OC capo contribu
developer Modesto a capo contribute a
Samana a supposes a votre professor
Lucas a sua da Vila Maxima Reno Air open
chakra a la gente que como que la cosa
petrol service the population
Ono's a paladin oval Aaliyah's rob a
freak given at Meza Talia's Europa freak
CLRS Salomon CIRA Duman economic
political diplomatic chakra Corey Pavin
siddhappa province a diffusion Alianza
the parochial synergy partisan Avila a
magic system accepting and a twin
european the matron place including
Kosovar conv apple a real magic to a
traverse a tornado son prism a mess a
patron so made artista given country
population partly a vacant discretely
avocados avocado basil pasta news of
embezzled purposes a partisan Avila
Avex a population donk avec truant
artists encode Ivar news aloe embarked
aboard a wish
avec l'ambassadeur Del Rio European
dancer fish knows Alan Parker Odysseus
ville de la côte d'ivoire moon our own
pants advanced efficient a shaft New
Zealand Peter Shantae
manual or sattva Upali Donny magic fair
to Aditya population say oh she devil
says salad novel approach a joke
accountant eco on an important channel
under container with OC mantra cat
reversal music on pran canal de
comunicación track legible
properly as a population dr. prophet
Elisha necropolis a massage a to LA
governor
Eva cachaça donggu bismuth Lucretia
occurred a developer Madison PE calico
to Satan canal on Teresa Satan free
canal [ __ ] pasady massage c'est pas
quoi ça nous somme la música enter on
Tina Turner paavana Papa Venetian to
pour vous avez vous possessiveness ash
universal
[Applause]